hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in the 2017
ulti box Norway championship between
Magnus Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura this
is a game from round three and a lot of
you have been requesting this game like
really a lot of you I don't remember the
last time I received so many requests
because of a certain photo that's been
going
um well that's been circulating online
it is a photo by Annie Leibowitz um
where she took a photo of I believe uh I
don't know if they were in the same room
because some people say they were some
people say they weren't of a Messi and
Ronaldo and uh he will let me just show
you the photo I'm sure you guys have
already seen it but this is the photo
and they have this position on the
chessboard which is not a chessboard
it's actually a briefcase on top of a
bigger briefcase or is that a suitcase
uh so the position on the board is
actually from the game Hikaru versus
Magnus from the 2017 uh ulti box Norway
championship and uh as it turns out it's
it's a it's a very nice game so you guys
requested me to show it uh and that's
exactly what we are going to do uh so
let's check out the game and what's also
interesting about this tournament is
that uh if you remember in 2016 uh
Magnus also had a World Series
championship match he faced uh none
other than Sergey kariakin and it was a
very very intense match Magnus even lost
one classical game and then he was able
to retaliate and uh well take take the
title or rather retain the title but
what's even more interesting is that
both Magnus and kayaking are playing in
this event and out of the 10 people that
were playing Magnus got Ninth Place in
the end the only one behind Magnus in
10th place was Sergey kariakin so I
thought it was really funny that the
world chess champion in the World Series
Championship Challenger basically took
second and last the second place in in
the early second to last place in this
this event but this is the game from the
from the this suitcase uh we we can so
sorry about that we can show it one more
time and there you have it now let's
check it out uh and uh Magnus opens with
Ponte E4 we have pawned the C5 by Hikaru
uh the Sicilian Defense is on the board
Knight to F3 D6 and pawn to D4 we have
characters captors Knight to F6 and now
Knight to C3 we have A6 the Knight of
variation is on the board and now Pawn
to H3 this is the atoms attack instead
of H3 at pretty much any move here with
white is is a valid move you can really
play anything here and it's it will be a
good move but H3 is a very well known uh
theoretical uh move and now Hikaru plays
a Ponte G6 which is not that common okay
geez uh H3 also isn't that common it's
White's seventh most popular reply but
the G6 usually here they play E6 or E5
but Hikaru goes G6 and now we have Pawn
to G3 by Magnus uh Knight the C6 with E3
by the bishop Bishop D3 and now Bishop
to G7 with Bishop to G2 and there is a
game uh that was played in 1961 between
tarasho and Victor korshnoy that ended
ended in a draw where Bishop to D7 was
played but here Hikaru just plays
castles and it is now as of move nine
that we have a completely new game uh
rather that we had a completely new game
in 2017 and Magnus also just castles
with knights the D7 now you can play E5
you can play F5 you can shoot the Knight
to C5 to b60 E5 all depend uh depends on
what white plays so B3
opening up this diagonal but as you'll
see it's not really a problem Magnus is
going for some sort of a setup where you
you will have a opponent B3 pawn and C4
the Knight will come to D5 sort of a a
maruti type structure so Knight captures
on D4 Bishop captures Bishop captures
Queen captures and now Pawn to B6
preparing to feed and get to the light
Square Bishop Knight to D5 and the
bishop to B7 we have Pawn to C4 uh and
now Pawn to E5 you could also start by B
with B5 Hikaru goes E5 first he kicks
away the queen queen to E3 and now Pawn
to B5 challenging the C4 Pawn Rook 8 to
C1 and now B captors and C4 Magnus
recaptures with the Rook he wants to
double up on the C file and now Hikaru
goes for Bishop captures on D5 the
bishop here is pretty much useless and
the Knight here is a monster so uh you
know you don't have to think twice about
capturing this so captures captures A5
and now we have Rook F to C1
and it's uh not easy to assess this
position but what you can see is that if
Hikaru can play F5 then he's gonna have
uh he will be able to put a lot of
pressure here in the center Magnus on
the other hand has this very strong D5
Pawn defended by the bishop he controls
E6 and C6 squares uh he has full control
over the C file both of the Rooks are on
the C file and he has the A and B Pawn
which is uh well the the hikaru's one a
pawn is a majority and he will be able
to create a pass Pawn with A3 and B4 so
that's basically the uh well story of
the position so Knights the C5 we have
A3 preparing B4 and now Hikaru does go
for Pawn to F5 we have B4 Magnus now
we'll create a past Pawn a capture sun b
for a captures on B4 and now Knight to
D7 we have rooked the C6 and now
attacking the D6 pawn and Hikaru now
doesn't really have time to to waste he
could defend with some like Rook df6 or
maybe Queen to B8 he go was for the
attack Pawn to F4 and Okay g captures e
captures on F4 Queen to E6 which checked
the D6 Pawn will fall now so what did
Hikaru have in mind here uh well he goes
Rook to F7
uh not King G7 King G7 looks weird
because after Rook to C7 you still have
to play Rook to F7 and then Queen
characters on D6 uh and the white uh is
just uh well you haven't really achieved
anything by wasting a move with King to
G7 so instead Rook to F7 by Hikaru we
have Queen captures on D6 and now Queen
to G5 putting pressure on that Bishop
preparing Pawn to F3 which will be very
unpleasant and here Magnus goes for King
to H1 he just gets the king out of
Harm's Way this check with Rook to C8
check isn't really all that much King
will be very safe on G7 not much you can
do here so instead just King to H1 and
still Pawn to F3 and now the problem
with F3 isn't that if you capture that
The Rook will capture also your knight
will be hanging on D7 the problem is if
you capture on F3 then Knights the E5
and it's very hard to defend the F3
Bishop is hanging also the rokan C6 is
attacked there's just no good way to
play this if Rooks d8 check King G7 and
you can't even capture an A8 because the
rook and C1 is hanging so black would be
very very close to winning here
so instead after F3 Bishop to F1 by
Magnus and now Knight to F6 by Hikaru
Queen to E6 you could also consider a
queen trade but then okay captures
captures magnets is up upon Rook A2 and
Hikaru with full control over the second
rank uh definitely would have
compensation for the pawn but it was uh
it was definitely a nice attempt the
Knight can maybe come into the game via
the four square so it would be a very
interesting position but here Queen T6
by Magnus King to G7 and now Rook the C7
Magnus offers a rook trade and basically
forces a rook trade as Queen captures
and F7 is the threat Rook captures on C7
Rook captures with check and now even
King the H6 and this is the only good
Square for the king any other Square for
example you got the a trade Queen to E7
and there's no stopping Checkmate if you
go Rook to G8 it's not a problem just
Pawn to D6 and okay you you have
prevented Checkmate but you have zero
counter play this this will come and
then the 7 Pawn becomes weak so you
would just lose King the H6 is the only
move that keeps the car in the game we
have Queen to E1 by Magnus now
uh and Rook to A2 as of course you know
that F2 will become a Target and here
Rook the E7 by Magnus uh if you go to
pawn to D6 first then maybe trying to
advance that fast Pawn doesn't really do
all that much as hikaru's reply would be
the same as it was in the game so Rook
D7 was played and now Hikaru has two
choices does he go for it right away or
does he first try something if you play
something like Rook the C2 uh then you
you just trade everything let's say
queen E3 Queen captures Rook captures
and now Knight captures and D5 Rook
captures and Knight captures on B4
trades down into a completely equal end
game so uh there's really not much point
in trying to go for anything here and
you can't reach that white king all the
way on H1 so Hikaru plays the only move
that's left and that is Knight to G4 uh
so now there's really not much you can
do you have to capture sdf2 Pawn is now
hanging H captures on G4 and now Hikaru
just goes for the queen H4 check King
you want Queen capture Sanji for
checking H1 Queen H4 checking to G1
Queen G4 King H1 Queen Tage for check
King to G1 and queen to G4 and he was in
this position on move 40 that Magnus and
Hikaru agreed to a draw or rather it was
a draw by threefold repetition but they
did reach move 40 at
um not to be able to claim it because I
think they actually repeated four times
but I think there was a rule like you
have to reach move forward in in order
to draw the game or something like that
or maybe it wasn't I don't know
uh but yeah very nicely done by uh both
of them magnets was really pushing for
the win here but Hikaru just kept his
cool the entire the entire game and uh
well in the end there was nothing more
to be done he just forced a nice draw
with that night sacrifice uh but yeah I
like I really thought it was funny that
uh Magnus and karakin who who played for
the World Chess Championship title got
the last and second to last place in
this tournament uh which is uh well
which is pretty incredible I mean okay
for one of them to have a bad event but
for both of them that's pretty
spectacular especially Magnus who is
playing in his home country of Norway uh
like I'm not sure if this is the worst
top level event that Magnus ever played
in but I'm pretty sure it is if you guys
know of any better example or also do
share in the comments uh because I
really can't think of uh even one uh but
yeah that's basically the story behind
this uh photo by Annie Leibowitz it was
uh I think it was for yeah it was for
Louis Vuitton and uh for I believe they
make suitcases and in briefcases uh so
yeah and yeah at first I thought they
again messed it up because there appears
to be more squares uh on the board but
only after actually looking at the photo
I realized it wasn't the chessboard it
was actually uh a suitcase and okay
maybe it doesn't have to have an eight
by eight board but okay uh I thought you
guys
would be interested in that because you
have requested me to show this game so
much on all the platforms that um I I
use but this is the actual photo uh from
the 2017 uh ulti box Norway Chess
Championship and this is Magnus and
Hikaru shaking hands uh before the start
of the game you can see that they look
much much younger than they do now
Magnus even has his glasses which is
weird as he doesn't have them now but he
probably had his uh site corrected or or
maybe he didn't I don't know maybe maybe
he he wore them just to confuse his
opponents like maybe Victor corcinoy did
in the olden days
uh who knows uh but yeah that's the game
and the story of the photo hope you guys
enjoyed it it's it's a very nice photo
so uh you know uh yeah I really hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank uh
Carmen polifronio Sinister Pon ravching
reptiles YouTube B4 AI mind and Gordon
solars for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day